modern feminism but well the thing is
you know modern feminism is
single-handedly responsible for
destroying the future of our society
sorry I'm very I feel barely strong in
that statement because they are trying
to castrate men and
um take their balls and put them in
their purse and then allow women to take
the lead and to be non-binary and all
these things and I have no problem with
any uh people who identify that way
however in order to have a thriving
functioning Society we need masculine
and feminine energy to co-create
together to have Offspring together to
raise that family unit and that is what
um is going to be responsible for future
Generations in our society functioning
so on and so forth but modern feminism
is coming in and taking that away yeah
and I think that's um
yeah I'd like to have that conversation
because
it's kind of alluded to before whether
it's politics whether it's media whether
it's masculine and feminism there's
Corrections that are needed and there's
over Corrections like we talked about
this last time the 1920s in women's
suffrage movement I think we can all
agree yeah women should vote absolutely
okay so like the initial first wave
feminism we got no problem with that
correct second wave feminism came in in
like the madman era in the 50s 60s yeah
women can work correct they should if
they want to work day and age we need
yes we need two incomes sometimes
sometimes or it's like I'm not gonna
tell you you need to stay in the kitchen
it's your choice and women can work from
home even now do whatever you want
whatever you want yeah but third wave
feminism is where they basically said
you don't need a man you can do it
yourself they tell you to go home and
put a plastic dildo that vibrates 360
degrees inside and does 50 000 pulses
per second then they get mad at men and
say why can't you make me come
sounds dangerous well [ __ ] why would
you why would you if you're putting
something like that inside of you on a
regular basis no man on the planet can
compete with that yeah and then and then
you can't even make yourself orgasm
because 70 some percent of women only
orgasm through clitoral stimulation they
do not have vaginal orgasms that means
G-spot and deeper walls are g-spotting
up and 37 percent of women don't orgasm
at all like never so yes she's been
faking it so but all of this again is
chiching it's money
you know the prawn industry
um the sexual or prawn is the toys
that's all in that industry it's it's
Sim culture it's not helping families
it's not helping the family Dynamic it's
destroying the polarity between
masculine and feminine energy think
about it think about I know all of y'all
have watched porn so don't lie and say
you have it but think about the the
money shot that everyone fast forwards
to just go there in your mind for a
moment with me that shot is the shot of
what balls and penis
really think about it
you see that you see the what we call
the Yoni in Sanskrit the womb but what
you're really seeing is balls and penis
moving in and out oh yeah I went
someplace else the money
I went someplace the precursor to the
next one yeah the other one they're
doing that and that is Money Shot we
have a different opinion on money shot
that's usually like around this area yes
sorry second money shot but what they're
doing is that they're they're
focusing on that because a lot of men
tend to watch that and then it starts
homosexualizing them they start becoming
like like what I'm saying what do you
mean
when you're when you're focused on
balls and eggplant for most that's
they're not showing like they don't go
and show all the women like there's the
the main focus shots are on that it's a
subconscious trying to make men more
homosexual no no I mean I don't know if
that's I believe that because if that's
the that's if that's the money shot
you're referring to I'm fast forwarding
right there to the actual money so have
you actually ever thought about that
though why they why they zoom in so much
on that can you actually make men more
homosexual listen we have this
conversation all the time down low man
you know about this about most of the
African-American men who actually have
functioning normal lives have wifey have
children or prominent members of society
and then they are sleeping with men
under like not telling anyone I'm Gonna
Keep It on the deal yeah so ask me again
have I heard about that have you heard
of that no I've not heard anything about
that they show that in TV shows a lot
what like it's a it's a real it's a real
thing
I just I have such a hard time
understanding this because we were
having this conversation earlier we'll
talk about that about Tom Brady whatever
oh yeah I don't know guy I mean I like I
played football in high school I played
football in college I've always been on
a sports team I hang with dudes I I roll
with like I'm a dude right I don't know
any of my homies
guy friends who like guys and they have
told me some prominent figures in
Charleston South Carolina that's correct
sleeping
and they're like hey you know you better
not tell anyone like I've had a guy
friend who was hooked up with prominent
figures
no I mean I've heard of it I have one
more question which conditions these are
guys who have been very masculine yeah
straight dudes they have not gone down
that path at all they didn't have like
that weird thing in college like nothing
this is they're just dudes and all of a
sudden they're like you know I think
it's time to suck some dick
it's conditioned Levin now that's what
I'm saying the poor the promise and you
think that's being conditioned Society
correct I have such a hard time grasping
this look it's big in Hollywood there's
I know Hollywood is not America though
not the world that's true fabricated
Society she's talking about you know the
Southern and that it is big in the South
especially in Atlanta it's huge down
there really yes
guys what are you doing I mean do what
you want to do I just I don't yeah but
that's the double life for me okay
that's that's the biggest problem that I
have if you want to be gay go be gay man
this isn't like gay bashing at all
go be gay but this whole like yeah I've
been straight my whole life and well you
know just
now it's sucking dick time you know like
I I just I don't get it it goes against
well again they're they're trying to
undermine the society it's all about
making money okay but that's but we're
saying two different things here you're
I'm saying just from a man like I'm a
person I make my own decisions you're
saying that they've watched a little too
much Real Housewives and they're just
like you know what not really yeah I
just you know I just uh Real Housewives
of Beverly Hills is doing it now it
sounds so sexy it's being conditioned
from every Walk of Life porn is the most
like obvious thing but even with like
look at Tick Tock go on Tick Tock and
watch couples today it makes me cringe
most of these women are parading their
men around like they're an idiot they
make them do all kinds of like silly
stuff and the women are like putting
them in situations where they don't look
like a Shiva they don't look like a guy
they look like a simp and so it's like
being it's being put in culture that
women are in control of the house that
we run the world thank you Beyonce we do
all this stuff and I'm seriously yeah
that whole thing we're perpetuating and
I'm not saying women shouldn't be
independent they shouldn't feel
confident they should blah blah blah but
that's not what's happening we are
switching gender roles like literally
and this is not conducive for a healthy
functioning passionate intimate orgasmic
relationship or just for the future of
our children so if you like that clip
click right here to watch another or if
you want to watch the entire saucecast
click right here
[Music]